[Music]
hello everyone I'm done Master Denis
borscht
this is games you should know by heart
and today I'm going to talk about what
I've learned from Paul Harris and mija
Botvinnik Karis ball was one of the
greatest players an eternal second as
they said the Estonian never had the
chance to become a world champion he
challenged Alekhine but unfortunately
world war ii broke out so it never
really materialized mohabbat Winnick is
obviously known as a world champion a
very methodical player but both were
fans of something that's not very
popular these days and that is the
isolated pawn structure with the
isolated pawn they love playing on the
side of the isolated pawn now in today's
world it's like Apple for average people
people like Apple but they like apple
pie better so they don't really go into
the Tarrasch anymore because it's just
too much trouble and you have to play it
very aggressively so first and foremost
I'll show you the game between Bobek of
care and Charis Charis is famous for his
creative style his unusual style which
actually notched him a lot of points so
let's start NIDA three might have 6 C 4
C 5 d 4 C takes Knight takes c6 Knight
c3 Bishop e2 d5 now you might argue as a
viewer that this is not the tirage well
let me show you a different move order
so d4 d5 c4 e6
III Knight f6 Knight f3 c5c takes it
takes Bishop e2 knight c6 we are here
already so there are many multiple ways
of getting this isolated pawn structure
which will happen after say castles
Bishop d2 Bishop d6 should be takes d
takes d5 and Bishop takes and well in
general the pawn can get very weak in
the long term so if you have an isolated
pawn you have to play very aggressively
and with a principled attitude so coming
back to the game not a three was played
the four takes knight c6 the five takes
knight c3 Bishop d6 there's usually two
major ways of playing these positions
either putting the Bishop on c5 but
usually the post the bishop on d3 or d6
as it's a reverse position so it's on
these six right now Knight takes c6 B
takes c6 castle of castle in general
White gets a little bit better but black
will get attacking chances b3 and how
should black try and continue build an
attack in this type of position you
already know that black will have to
play energetically to show that he has
good play for this week d5 and c6
structure so black must go for the king
yes so the suggestion is Queen c7 rook
e8 they play that way but Karis decided
to be even more energetic and build a
different kind of battery on the H to be
a diagonal which is he played Queen e7
so unlike Queen c7 which is also an idea
he's trying to bring the Queen to e5
directly threatening mate now for
example if why it would be totally
clueless and play Bishop f3 did the idea
of bringing the Knight to e2 Cara's most
likely would have jumped on this
occasion played Queen e5 and double
attack on H 2 and C 3 and after G 3 he
would thank his luck and win the piece
obviously babakov knew what's gonna
happen so I played Bishop b2 I should we
continue here obviously with Queenie 5
once we've planned an idea
we must go through with it and just do
it
Queen e5 and there's only one way to
stop the mate with g3 because f4 would
drop the e3 pawn so that's not a
possible solution now the black Queen on
e5 is very active but might run into
some tactical ideas let's say like not
be 5s so black decides to move it to an
active Square where would you put the
Queen on e5 yes g5 why Queen g5
to nourish work yes yes
yes yeah
Bishop h3 Luke the eighth and now he
played queen g5 so the idea was as well
pointed out that we are kind of staring
down at White's King also planning this
age 5h4 idea now that's actually very
annoying because if black manages to
push the pontil h4 it's going to be near
mate f4 no wonder that book at babakov
is trying soba Beckham is actually
trying to chase away the Queen Queen g6
and not h6 because he still it has this
H 5 H 4 in his back of his mind
Queen g6 Bishop d3 green eight-six
why not Bishop f5 why didn't care us
play this move he has a philosophical
reason for not playing it and the reason
is that he wants to keep as many pieces
as possible because if he runs out of
pieces he'll be saddened by this pawn
structure forever so Queen eight six
nine a4 Bishop b4 already kind of
bothering that rook on e1 Bishop c3
exchanging that and surprisingly in this
tarush kind of pawn structures getting
rid of the black squared Bishop is okay
and this for some reason even advised
obviously not when we actually have
mating threats on h2 or on the Kings
side but when those threats are gone
exchanging the black squared bishop is a
must or even just a very good idea just
in general rook d6 Knight c5 rook e8
very good classical move by black Bishop
f1 Nagi what is black planning after
Knight g4 what is Paul Karason vision
okay so black is kind of hinting on
taking and just present Inge all over
the place either taking on the e3 or on
h2 also a fight would take on h3 Queen
takes h3 suddenly we see how good rug d6
was poor Karis envisioned this rook to
move to h6 already putting a lot of
pressure on the h2 pond let's see let's
say rook c2 and rook h6
and black is again threatening Knight
takes h2 it's also good to mention that
Queen d2 runs into this splendid idea of
d4 and if it takes then black has a
beautiful tactical solution here
it's black to move and when
yes
mm-hmm and F Queen takes H - that's not
quite mate yet King G - and then check
and we'll take everything and we'll be a
whole rook up so this positions even
though look in osius at first sight can
get awfully dangerous if white misplace
it
so Knight g4 takes rookie 2 rookies 6 he
didn't fall for the Queen d2 d4 trick
rookie 2 rookies 6 now White had a
threat in this position what was white
threatening actually he had a very nice
Petrosyan kind of defending move in this
position that white was aiming for what
was that
if white would be on move what would why
play
yes
yes it's it looks very awkward but okay
let's let me play a pretty suspicious
move by black but if we play clean f1
and it's a very good defensive move
because this clean on h3 was very very
strong so after it moves away white
might even consider bringing the Queen
to f3 or g2 and he would have a decent
position now caris wants none of this
and plays rook h6 actually suspecting
his opponent of trying to bring the
Queen to f1 but it doesn't work now
because we'll take and take the h2 pawn
so Queen d2 and now he plays rook g6 and
actually this is a sign of a world-class
player he senses your plan stops your
plan and after you chose a totally
different plan he switches back to his
original plan now after rook g6
he hints on a plan that V was planning
to do five six moves ago but I think
it's a great idea again what is it yes
what's wrong with Luke Sita
mm-hmm Brooksie - it would hang the e3
pawn so it's not a great idea at the
moment Queen d2 room g6 so what is black
trying to reheat as an idea what is he
trying to do again after so many moves
yes yes h 5 h 4 plan again
must have been annoying to be white
always threatened by h 5 h 4 e 4 h 5 is
coming he 598 6
hello I'm coming rogue G 2 Queen c8 and
actually it's not an accident that black
drops the Queen back to c8 because H 4
would run into a cute little trick why
to move and went
yes g4 and this time the rook on c3
would play peek-a-boo with the Queen on
h3 and that would be the end of it so
Karis the eternal second so pretty good
player himself decides to keep that
clean for later before h4 continuing
with his plan Knight b3h takes H takes
Queen h3 you know the stranger comes
back time to time but he's a known
visitor on h3 94 nygean in fact I think
Kara's deserves a lot of credit for his
creative play the way he plays is quite
unusual and innovative you don't see
many of these games and these d5
isolated pawn structures so I think it's
kind of a treat seeing him play the
Tarrasch defense rook takes c6 takes
knight c6 and now again Karis comes up
with a splendid idea
a splendid maneuver that will actually
win him this game
even if we think logically our queen is
superbly placed on h3 the night is just
a beauty on g4 so so we only need one
more guy to actually win the game yes
the rook but how should we maneuver with
it yes
rookie 6a plea go rook takes d5 rook h6
Queen da check King gate 7 and actually
that's why chess is beautiful if you
play strategically and you position your
pieces well they'll reward you greatly
white is completely lost because his
pieces even though some ponds up totally
uncoordinated and we have a huge threat
right now for black yes Queen h1 and
it's kind of tough to defend against
that so white gave a check now should we
stop that yes g6 we're not gonna go
rogue g6 no way g6 King f1 and it's
black to move and win the game yes and
after rubgy won
no there's an even stronger move there
yes yeah green age-1 yes yes and this
was kind of a hard-working queen in this
game the Queen moving around the whole
board and ending on c6 and Karis won his
game with the scintillating moving Queen
alright so moving on to our second hero
Botvinnik now both Vinick you have to
know is a different type of player he is
methodical and is rarely going for very
entertaining or inventive play he
studies at home comes up with concepts
and tries to play as precisely as
possible so we're going to see a totally
different way of playing the Taurus now
let's see 5 c5 either 396 e6 the
same-old same-old we've seen this now
the bishop on b5 and the bishop runs on
c5 castles castles b3 and now but Vinick
plays a move that is kind of the staple
very important move in this type of
positions that we will see in later
games as well yes so what is the move
how can black stabilize the pawn on d5
yes Bishop e6 and this is such a great
move it's catching on in different
variations recently but both Vinick
showed this already against this match
in against but against Petrosyan now I
heard the suggestion of d4 but d4
doesn't work usually because of the idea
of night a4 and we can't defend the d4
pawn and the Bishop on c5 simultaneously
and after we move the bishop
it will just get overloaded and we lose
the d4 pawn that is why they don't play
d4 in these type of positions so early
so Bishop e6 a very good methodical move
Bishop b2 Queenie 792 and always in
these middle game positions we have the
first question where to post our rooks
so how did black continue posting his
rooks about the rooks c8 one of them
will go there and it goes there yes rook
c8 a3 and rook F d8 yes that was your
suggestion correct
so there's actually many ways of posting
the rooks whenever the rook is on c8 and
d8 that usually signals positional play
that the idea of trying to make d4 work
in the long run obviously I'm not saying
d4 will work now with plenty of pieces
eyeing the d4 square later Knight d4
especially it's not quite possible after
90 for Bishop g4 Bishop g4 is played now
as the d5 pawn is off the hook there's
no pieces attacking it so the bishop has
no reason to stay passive remember we
have an isolated pawn we must play
aggressively Bishop g4 Bishop e2 how
should we continue here in general most
of our pieces are Val plays the queen is
fine the bishop is super active hitting
on the d4 Knight the knight on c6 is c6
is context ton the knight on c6 is
contesting the d4 Knight but we have one
more piece that is not participating
enough yes
yes so how can we activate the knight on
f6 yes 94 jumping in also trained eyes
will see that there's not also hints and
looks at this F 2 square hoping to get
sacrificed there in the long run maybe
what we'll see if it happens
Queen D 3 and now black plays a very
crafty move in general
White has a nice grip on the d4 square
but by moving the knight to d4 from c3
black got really active so if we're
really active that means we can go for
the King and that's what what wenneck
does he plays Bishop d6 he realizes that
the d4 is too well protected now there's
no way we can break through so he moves
his pieces into attack mode he actually
has asylum threat in this position what
is black threatening here
it's mostly an exchange your operation
but it is it is pretty strong in order
to find this good idea for black we have
to notice which is the weakest point in
White's position yes
Bishop takes every would just get rid of
our good bishops so don't we don't want
to lose that bishop yet so which is the
weakest spot again in whites position
yes no when I say the weakest means the
pawn that we can reach and actually
attack yes yes the h2 pawn that's what
she wanted to say exactly the H DuPont
so how can we come closer to that h2o
yes mm-hmm Queen f6 Queen h6 it's a
standard idea could be a little
dangerous because it runs into this
Bishop but the other idea is Knight e5
so let's say if I place something like
rugby one you can go Knight e5 takes
Queen takes e5 takes takes Queen takes
g2 and double attack my friend hitting
on g4 and on f2 and black has very good
play in general but if he doesn't play
for example rook D one let's say place
b4 then we still have this ninety five
idea and queen h2 as a direct checkmate
so that's a very good idea to keep in
mind so you played g3 for that same
reason so 95 doesn't work it would run
into Knight takes e5 and now the bishop
on g4 is undefended for reals
because if takes takes Bishop takes e5
we exchange too many pieces and that's
good for us when we have an ice a lot
isolated pawn so he plays Knight c5
queen bee 194 and he comes back because
he feels all of my pieces are well
positioned I don't need to do anything I
posted everything in there right
position so this should be fine Queen d3
Knight c5 Queen D 1 white rejects the
repetition of a draw so night II 6
what's the point of knight c6 e 6
I mean 96 yes
yes yes it's a very strong move what
what's Vinick played it's actually very
rare that black players play Knight e6
usually black moves around with 94 and
it's a typical position but 96 is very
original trying to undermine the d4
square as pointed out rook e1 Bishop c5
now notice that both Vinick realized
that he's not gonna mate when there's a
g3 pawn there so he said okay now I'm
going to undermine your d4 square them
96 rook e1 Bishop c5 Knight takes so
there was way too much pressure at this
point on patrols Ian's position so he
decided to exchange one pair of peace B
takes c6 before there should be six
actually Knight e5 is an interesting
suggestion in this position because
after that say take stakes why might
hope for a slight advantage because of
these big pawns but the black pieces are
well coordinated so black shouldn't meet
that worse so before this should be six
Queen a4 and now black plays this
amazing move of Queen e8 we'll see why
rook II a d1 and black still didn't gave
up on the idea of breaking through the
d4 but for that he needs to strengthen
this battery along this age 51 diagonal
and he comes up with the true original
idea here yes
f-five is close actually but Vinick
played f6 he didn't play f5 because he
was a little bit afraid of getting too
many pong weaknesses but with f6 he
actually takes away this a five square
for White's night and gets ready to
swing over to h5 between D 1 C 5 now as
we talked about it then you have an
isolated pawn you have to be active but
also exchanges are good because in
general if you only lose this deep on
you might get some contour chances later
on as we will see in the game Knight d4
Bishop takes c2 9 Queen take c2 takes
takes Knight g5 so it's important to
notice that even in the endgame you can
still play actively you don't have to
wait patiently for y to circle around
your deep on so Knight g5 threatening
the pretty cute idea of Knight f3
triple-check kind of hitting on all of
the rooks and the King King G 294 Brook
d1 and now but when it comes up with a
very ambitious solution to his problems
which is much in the spirit of the
Tarrasch well we have an active knight
on e4
but that lone knight on e4 won't help us
we need some buddies to actually make it
work yes
Bishop's c7 with the aim of yeah so so
nights love to coordinate this rooks so
how can we make it happen
so they can coordinate well yes yes he
takes before and actually this is very
edgy move by Botvinnik because we don't
like having isolated pawns they can get
a little weak so saying that I don't
mind I'll just get a better look
it's kind of an edgy decision he thinks
before Brooksie - but what Botvinnik
claims and he claims correctly is this
rook and Knight tandem will prove that
his position is not worth to white just
because of their strength
Bishop d4
although Petrosyan will try to circle
this d5 pawn and show that all that pawn
is more important than active play
Bishop takes d4 rook takes d4 rugby -
what is rugby - hinting at it's also a
very principle idea by black yes
yes he wants to make some space for the
other guy on c2 and if that happens that
will be the last day for white because
those powerful double rooks on the
seventh rank are usually decisive with a
knight on e4 that's just too much
h4 rook c8 rook takes d5 can get three
but by luck or I don't know what Y
manages to hold because the only thing
that black would need to do is like an
IG v check that my just Y just stopped
so it just gives another check kingi 294
and it turns out to be a dynamically
equal position because for example let's
say why do they played h3 just show how
it would work then rook c8 takes rook c2
and Don now we would have Knight g5
check so what had to defend against this
Knight g5 check otherwise black would
have been winning it takes takes and
it's a piece up but obviously Petros
Young who will be a future world
champion plays h4 takes rook c2 king f3
here in 94 and basically because of the
repetition they agreed to a draw just it
deserves a mention that it would be
suicidal to move the night because the
rooks would come in with full force and
after like King g2 or King age one these
rooks are just too powerful and after
like 92 rookie to here these positions
can get very uncomfortable for whites
especially because after Knight G to its
mate so I've learned a lot from these
two games and in general Karras and both
Vinick or great-great isolated pong
players and in fact I studied many of
these ideas from Paul Karason book in
his book called Paul Karras teaches so I
felt confident after seeing all these
games and played myself an isolated game
in my youth
so e4 c5 Knight f3 knight c6 c3 now this
is a way of getting isolated pawns as
the c3 Sicilian Knight f6 usually
there's two ways of playing one of them
is d5 or Knight f6 bunner's who is
actually a GM right now and part of the
hunk best of the best in Hungary plays
Knight f6 v5 95 d4 takes takes c6 Bishop
c4 d6 this is a different pawn structure
but soon I'll get soon we'll get into
that isolated pawn structure again rook
the Avant Knight b6 and my opponent is
kind of planning to play d5 but as we've
seen in Cara's game the first thing you
learn is to stop your opponent from
doing their own plans so what did I play
in this position I really don't want him
to play d5
yes well that would lose my bishop pair
and I wouldn't want that yes II takes d6
exactly and now we are in isolated pawn
territory already Queen takes d6 and in
general I would love to have my bishop
on d3 but I can't post it there right
now because not before we should be for
and this we had moved f5 and he plays
this he would have played this move I
guess because after this I would lose
the bishop there and also have an
isolated pawn and that's kind of a no-no
I don't want that so I played it should
be 395 and I just went oh no I'm not
giving you that Bishop Knight d5 and in
general I've learned that if your
opponent's pieces move away from c6
especially the knight moves away from c6
there's always a jump that could be used
in this type of positions
I played Knight c3 first I can test the
knight on d5 because eventually I do
want to play d5 and breakthrough if
possible so Knight takes c3 B takes c3
Queen c7 and now I use the fact that
blacks Knight is out of place and not on
c6 how did I do that
yes
No
not Queenie five
because usually as we talked about it in
these type of positions I'm trying to
mate
I'm not going to exchange Queens if
possible
yes Queeny for that's a very principled
idea but what I was aiming in this
position is to occupy that if I square
it my night if my opponents night is a
way that's actually the way to punish
your opponent for misplacing their night
now this is actually a pawn sacrifice
and he didn't take on c3 but I saw this
very very nice idea for white which
tactically justifies my plane
notice that my rook is hanging on a1 but
I really don't want to lose a Tempe that
will be one yes there should be two now
the bishop is taboo because if you do
I'll say thank you and take your queen
so obviously you have to take and move
your queen away but then the whole
concept will work and we'll do what we
always wish to do in an isolated
position isolated pawn position yes No
you always want to break open in the
center how we do that yes
d5 bam opening up both bishops and after
a takes rook takes d5 I'm hinting ideas
on the King side and also winking on the
Queen side a little bit if Bishop e6
I'll thank you for the participation and
I'll take your knight on e5 you can't
really do much because my bishops just
take away all the squares
he played Bishop d6 instead now I played
Queen d3 in general Queenie for as
suggested before is an idea but that
would just run into f5 with which would
win at MP for him and I don't want to
get free tempies that's not the way I
play here Queen d3 f v g6 would be the
other way of playing f5 rook e1 what's
the idea of rook e1
did you raise that yeah
well for a while I can't play d5 but as
he played f5 I have an eternal square on
e5
so I bolster it that rook e1 rook b8 see
for now the c4 pawn is taboo because
Bishop takes c5 rook takes e5 and if
Knight takes e4 my rook says hello to
you again and I'll take the night and if
Queen takes c4 my rook does the job and
takes the knight again it's kind of a
crafty rook so c4 rook d8 and this rook
on da is very annoying so how can I just
say shoo - that rook
yes yes I went seshu rook e8 and if I
chase that rook away once
now I'm gonna chase it away twice go
away go back to f8 where you belong
passively but obviously my young
opponent at that time didn't want to do
as I won he objected and played knight
c6 instead now I notice the pattern in
this position the rook and the queen is
on one diagonal so in general we have a
piece that likes to use these factors so
what did I play in this position yes
yes Bishop f4 so I like my position very
much as I have a lot of cross pressure
on blacks position now my opponent was
in big trouble
obviously burning a lot of time as it's
quite tough to move with blacks so he
took on e5 hoping that I would take with
the bishop and then he could take with
the night but he didn't expect my next
move
so why to play and get a substantial
advantage yes
rook takes e5 exactly it will take c5
yes because after Knight takes e5 Bishop
takes e5 my bishops welcome the two
guests on b8 and he ate and I just win
so Queen d8 rookie three asking where is
this route going well he had enough of
this position so he sacrifices the pawn
bishop takes B takes Bishop takes e5 now
obviously this position is glorious for
me but it is still an opposite colored
Bishop position so what is a potential
danger yes
yeah drawing so if I exchange everything
off I might might run into trouble but
the other tidbit about having Queens on
the board in opposite colored bishops
the one who has the pressure is likely
to be much much better and we can see
that this Bishop after rook b7 is eyeing
this juice a little pawn on g7 so I felt
there'll be some chances of mating here
the five creating a passed pawn if
possible Sita XE takes rook e7 Queen d4
Queen b6 I don't want it in exchange
greens now green b5 rope d1 just
defending everything you should be 7f 4
if you can do it bolster your [ __ ]
chips because this bishop will be again
eternal just like the knife previously
on the e5 rook c8 Queen a3 again kind of
double attacking on both a seven and a
seven
you ki eight Queen d6 broke f8h three
Luke f7 Bishop d4 Queen a for Brooke D -
what can we notice where am i posting my
pieces mostly what color yes
what color I'm putting my pieces dark
yes exactly so my point is I won my
pieces protected and also I want to
attack you on g7 sooner or later but
rook g3 the game continued at rook e8
Bishop e5 I'm not giving you an open
file no way this should be five room g3
Feeny for King h2 and the best way to
put your king in to safety and opposite
colored positions is to put your king in
the different color to your opponent's
Bishop Queen e1 would be to a for just
opening it up Bishop a4 Queen takes a6
I'm still upon up so I'm winning by now
Bishop d1 v c6 rookie 7 and why to move
and wrap the game up
yes yeah rook takes g7 and I emphasize
the fact that after here I'll meet you
on white squares this was kind of my
favorite game in the isolated pawn
structure but I played another one here
two against another grandmaster
Grandmaster Medved and surprisingly it's
gonna be a c3 Sicilian again which will
obviously lead to this isolated pawn
structure and we can see the return of
Bishop III just like in both winix game
where he played Bishop e6 which is
actually symmetrical C takes d4 C takes
d4 Knight f6 a3 why did I play a 3
instead of Knight c3 here yeah yeah so
Knight c3 might run into Bishop b4 ideas
which I didn't want because he could
exchange it off and exchanges are not
that great in the opening stage for
white so a3 Bishop e7 Knight c3 in d6
where should I post my bishop if I'm
planning to attack the King
yes yes because if I'm playing to open
up the position with d5 I want my bishop
on the A to G a diagonal if I want to
make my opponent as kind person I am I
have to post it on d3 castles castles b6
Queen e2 and this might look familiar
from the petrosyan but winning game
that's how we learn from the grades so
this should be seven now as I had more
aggressive intentions than both Winnick
in that position I will position my
rooks not on c1 on d1 but on rook d1 and
e1 rook the eight rook e1 h6 now he
plays h6 because if he would for example
play Bishop f8 I would jump to the
occasion and play Bishop g5 Bishop e7
back which would be kind of a sad move
then we have a move that we talked about
and could be pretty strong in this
situation and it's white to move and put
a lot of pressure on blacks position yes
yes yes correct
94 yes because what might really badly
wants is to attack the h7 pawn and put
pressure on the King side so you
correctly point out that night efore is
the most principled move in the position
so if it takes Queen takes e4 I hit on
that age 7 pawn and after g6 I will just
do the Charis and play Queen h4 already
tying my opponent up and I have huge
pressure in this position as for example
if he takes on g5 9 takes g5 my knight
and clean just coordinates perfectly I
have a huge attack here so he didn't
want any of that
therefore he played h6
Bishop b1 bishop f8 Bishop c1 g6 and if
we recall from previous games from the
Petrossian Botvinnik game we can realize
how we can switch plans now for white
here I played a move that actually
indicated more of a positional threat
instead of meeting ideas what did I play
here but in general g6 signals different
plan for whites so therefore I played
Bishop a2 with what intention what's my
intention after Bishop a - yeah I might
I the f7 pawn but there's too many pawns
in front of it therefore I want to play
d5 right yes d5 so he stops this Allah
Petrosyan
in plays 97 but as we learned if the
knight moves our Knight jumps into e5
now he realizes that his position is
getting very suspicious so he doesn't
play Bishop g7 he plays Bishop d5
instead but Bishop g7 would have ran
into this beautiful classical sacrifice
of Knight takes f7 and now I'm not just
winning
I'm mating because you can't even move
to it because King takes a seven mate
and after Queen f-18 f7 so playing with
the isolated pawn also has its benefits
not just a downside so after Bishop d5 I
realized that I need to decide the fact
which piece I should exchange on d5 and
IV and I came to the conclusion that the
knight is very useful because it
contests the d5 square but the bishop is
useless at this moment so I took on d5
Knight takes d5 and Henry pinpoints the
weakest point can be pinpoint the
weakest target in blacks position
weakest target in blacks position yes
f7 so how can we jump on that juicy
target yes you next three that's what I
played and now black is in trouble
because usually he would have this idea
of Knight f5 but then I would just jump
at him and play g4 and the f7 pawn false
so f5 has to be played and that's
already a good sign so the other
weakness I sensed and detected was the
8th 6 months of late night b5 can be 8
Queen age 3
sadly for him he has to play h5 but that
doesn't make his position look too
appealing Bishop g5 just occupying that
amazing square if possible Bishop g7
and now I make a long-distance move
pinpointing that this e 6 pawned it's a
little bit weak
yes Knight takes g6 is not really good
now because we're sacrificing something
when we already had a very good position
we don't need to do that so I played the
long-distance move of Queen b3 kind of
checking out that guy on e6 so rook e8
bishop takes c7 Bishop takes e5 that's
the sad necessity of the position
because the knight can't take because
then I'll take on e6 and if Brooke takes
I'll thank you again you go here takes
Queen takes Queen d5 and I win because I
have too much material so it takes on e5
rook takes e5 rook takes e7 and just
before
could consolidate I find a very nice
tactical idea in this position why to
move and win
yes
yes rook takes c6 rook takes SX is kind
of the question but then Queen takes d5
and the sad reality of this position is
that this rook on a it is a constant
weakness for example King f7 rook e1
queen see it or I ate Queen c8 let's say
96 check and we thank him for
participating actually 96 is not good
I'm sorry because that would run maybe
into Queen f6 but the easiest way is
just to capture I capture take
everything and I see seven wins so this
so it just rook takes c6 in this
position mints rook takes c6 plays rook
d7 route g6 King gate 7 rook g5 and I
just collect all the points possible
Lina for takes king g6 Luke h3 bouquet
8-pin g3 this is just technical part I'm
up plenty of pawns so I offer exchanges
takes rookie to be 400k to and I can
defend against this doubling with rook
f3 and after it takes takes g4 King g5
takes a king G to take h4 I just have
way too many ponds and that's how I
learned from Charis and Botvinnik how to
play the isolated point thank
you
[Music]